hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another interview i am
beyond thrilled to welcome austin crew
to the youtube channel to talk about his
new movie tank house and so many other
things because you have a lot of
exciting stuff happening right now
thank you for having me thank you so
much
the cool thing or one of the coolest
things ever is when i'm about to talk to
someone and i get an email about news
breaking for a particular project that
person is part of and it's going to
happen like the same day almost at the
same time yes absolutely
as a matter of fact i just talked to i
like cryptically talked about this next
project on the last interview but the
title wasn't released until minutes now
it is
i haven't here we could talk about that
one in fall but i have to go back to the
very very beginning i love asking people
this going back to day one what would
you say was the movie the performance
personal experience whatever it was you
had that first made you say to yourself
i have to be an actor and nothing else
i would say
it was sixth grade
and to be honest
my mom so i was always multifaceted and
i always did music and acting and and
every type of performance art and my mom
saw an elective drama and was like
you're joining drama
you're joining drama and so i went and i
joined it and ever since then
i have been going full throttle and i've
wanted to be on film and tv and now i'm
doing filming tv
yeah i love hearing it so
you are talented in a number of
different respects was there ever a
point where you felt the need to only
pursue one particular form of art over
the others
well i
would say that my calling
primarily is music from being a musician
um singing producing producing for other
people artists developing other people's
artists and and things like that and
growing up in atlanta that was my
bread and butter
but
from an academic standpoint
acting was i was always in the theater i
was always on the stage
and so then this empath came where i was
gonna go to nyu
and i was like what am i gonna study
and so i chose recorded music but then
my mom was like all right
so you're double majoring in drama and
music and i was like i cannot do that
because i physically am not able to do
that unless i'm able to clone myself and
go to two different classes that are
happening at the same time
the drama department at nyu goes from
nine to five
um and i'm pretty sure a lot of them
graduate in three years so
it's and you can't audition
while you're training so
i was like you know what i will star in
something sophomore year to get you off
my back and
fulfill that side of me and i ended up
being seaweed in nyu's production of
hairspray where i got my first agency
and then it kind of just like
went on from there but even before that
i was like justin bieber that year
before i was so
was recording the the major you end up
going with and you didn't double
i ended up going with recorded music to
the point where to the point where
by the time that i had booked my first
major project
which was atlanta so i was
19 20. i think i was 20 um when i did
atlanta and i was black justin bieber
um on atlanta fx
i had no
idea what a call sheet was i'm telling
you i did not know how to read a call
sheet until midway through daybreak
which was my first lead in a netflix
show so
i had no
you know training or anything and acting
is not like
when you go to a a job and then you have
an orientation with training and this
and that the third there's like this
expectation that you just know what
you're doing
um so i just faked it i have so many
questions about so you already mentioned
the call sheet i always love asking this
question is there any anything else that
seems like like super trivial about a
way that a show or a movie is made that
you wish you had the nerve to ask back
then that uh you know you were afraid to
ask someone
wow i've never been asked that um
[Music]
i would say
i'mma ask her oh i'mma ask the questions
but i am tactful on who i asked
so for example
i wasn't like about to ask the producers
of the project how to read the schedule
so i asked hair and makeup like i was
like
listen uh
how do what is the number
what is the number next to my name mean
and why do i keep on seeing it
everywhere like so they make so on a
call sheet for those who don't know a
call sheet is the schedule the roster
everything that you need to know from
the locations to every the the crew
members anything that's happening on set
any number to call um is on the call
sheet so any lines you have to memorize
is referenced on the call sheet so i did
not know
and
everyone has a number of ranking on the
call sheet so i did not know what my
number was
i literally would know what scene we
were doing and just memorized like
everything
in it without destroying
indiscriminately without any intention
because i didn't know now it's like oh
so i can memorize this and i don't need
to know the rest got it because i came
from the stage where you just memorize
the whole play and then whatever we're
working on we're working on but we know
the whole play and that is not how it
works adam
i love how many times i've asked that
question and how many people have told
me they'll ask those scary questions to
the hair and makeup department i feel
like
it's the safe space it is and it's the
most intimate space because
you know you see them first you see them
last and you know they're in they're
quite literally in your hair and you
know
anything that you like you know might
have to say or like might have to you
know like ask a question they're right
there with you so
you know
all right so to kind of help
bridge the gap between studying in
school and kicking off a career so you
said you did a production of hair spray
and then that's how you got
representation
yeah well that's how i got my first
representation
um
and yeah there was like scouts there at
nyu for the tnt that's tisch new theater
performance of hairspray and what that
is is a student-run student-led
um
production company
that is basically like a mini industry
and teaching the kids how to run
produce
set design
costume design choreographed and
potentially you know
put on the show at skurball
at nyu so it's like a real in-depth live
training of the industry
it was great so what's the reality of
being approached after a production does
someone like randomly come up to you and
say like hey i want to represent you
well you know what it's funny it's um so
after that particular so i'm read by
paradise love paradigm paradigm resource
at paradigm gang shout out val shout out
ryan
um
they found me
pretty early on but they slid into my
dms on
instagram so i had i met with an agency
when i was um doing that uh show doing
doing seaweed but
there was another agency
that had their eye on me based on
atlanta my performance in atlanta and
they slid in my dms the la offense i
remember um it was natalia
um and she was like listen like are you
in the area you live in la and i said
actually i'm going to new york i'm going
to nyu and i was studying abroad in
berlin at the time so i wasn't even in
the country
and they called me and said oh no we
have a new york office so i went to
their new york office when i got back
and
um
we've just been riding ever since me and
paradigm and they slid in my dms on
instagram so
i love asking about these relationships
so you had you had one opportunity a
potential there when when they slid into
your dms and started those conversations
what was it about them and their
approach to how they were going to work
with you that made you sure this is the
right team of people for me to commit
myself to
well one
i loved
the youth
i loved everybody at paradigm was all i
everyone that i met
i would say under probably 28
um
and they had their finger on the pulse
of
what i wanted
but also they had a vision for me they
had a vision for for you know they knew
that i did music they knew that i did
acting
and they saw me for the brand that i
could be not just you know oh this guy
that can read lines and listen about
them a few auditions
also
their offices are really really nice
their office is really nice the paradigm
office if anybody's ever been like they
know it's really really nice and um i
love scott mesker and like
just everybody that i met um there at
the time i think that he's he switched
agencies um recently but everybody that
i met there at the time and everybody
that's there now is just like incredible
and their energy is just right like you
just know when energy is right and and i
will say this
for anybody who is looking to get into
it and agencies and stuff not everybody
who just hands you an opportunity
is the right one
like just because they're saying
everybody's gonna have this huge
pitch in this huge thing but it's how
they treated me
you know any time that we spoke
we would have our own office
you know and with the glass and the view
and everything and i was just treated
with respect and treated like somebody
that really has so much something to
offer whereas you know some of these
other agencies out here
you know they'll
they'll have you waiting in the lobby
for an hour or something like that so
yeah makes me happy to hear that it's a
tough industry it's important to have
people you trust at your back yes and i
do i love my thing
so i have a role for myself i'm not
allowed to to not bring up book smart
whenever i talk to someone who is in the
book smart ensemble because i am deeply
obsessed with that
movie so
that right there was your very first
feature film so looking back on that
experience is there anything about the
way that set was run the material
anything at all that makes you now think
to yourself i am so glad to have had my
first feature making feature filmmaking
experience on that set with those people
looking back i would say
i've always felt
the most
safe the most
looked after like the most scene on
women run
sex
and olivia wilde
and allison jones because alison jones
is um was the casting director for book
smart and her eye is legendary iconic so
to have been chosen by her one was a
huge cosign i feel like industry-wide i
mean for anybody that
has a first with allison jones usually i
mean paul i mean you see all of these
people from freaks and geeks from from
amazing shows that have been casted by
her
have
longevities careers thereafter so it was
an incredible co-sign to just to even be
chosen by her but then once olivia got
in the in the fold and
just seeing how she directs and opening
up creative
um
opening up creative input to the actors
because she's an actor and she knows
what that is and she knows how to direct
a movie from that standpoint it was just
a flawless first experience and i am so
grateful to her for
just you know i didn't have that much
experience but to give me the the floor
as if i did wow and i'm still talking
literally i'm gonna see nico haraga
tonight i still talk with mason all the
time me and mason are like such good
friends out here like me and noah
so i have a request you go talk to mason
you get me scream six details and you
send them my way please okay i'm gonna
send i'm i'm your spy okay
now i mean never exposed it's never
going to work but i could try
thinking
with olivia right now because like
olivia is like very much in the
spotlight because book smart was her
feature directorial debut now she's
moving on to don't worry darling for her
second film and based on the trailer it
looks like a significantly larger and
very challenging project right there so
based on your experience working with
her if anyone out there is doubting her
abilities to kind of take it to the next
level in certain respects what would you
tell them to ensure that she is going to
pull that off well
i would say that they are referring to a
legendary icon visionary and let's not
forget to address her as such
i think
i think that there's a reason why she is
the white girl the white celebrity that
was chosen for the nights for what video
i think that there is a reason why she
is you know who she is she is olivia
wilde she has this vision she has this
eye
that when you if you have ever
appreciated her performance as an actor
those same choices and attention
intentionality that goes into her acting
performances
are
if not expanded and made
um exponentially like
more
noticeable even though they're more
subtle because she's behind the scenes
but it's like you can really see her
voice and her
tone on a project the more that you
start that people will start to see her
material drop
there will be no more doubt in people's
minds i think that she's incredible i
feel like that should be clipped out and
any time she does like a comic con or q
a like that needs to play to get
everyone
about
all right let's touch on tank house now
so i imagine that opportunity comes your
way there's a whole lot of reasons you
want to get involved in a production
like that but was there anything about
the people involved or the material that
that made you think that like this is
the right type of project for me and my
craft right now in my career
yeah well right that's very interesting
so i had just finished filming daybreak
and
that was my second major production
um after that was actually the first
production at all after book smart so
it's like i went from my first ever
movie to my first ever like lead netflix
show big crazy so to have a more
intimate passionate project
that reflected my time
as
a theater kid for the longest was just
it was a no-brainer i was like
i absolutely want to do this like
absolutely oh so many questions about
this now so jumping off what you just
said about it being shot like a little
while ago i was about to jump into your
future projects but it seems like this
came first
what is a new tool in your acting
toolkit so to speak that you can credit
to your experience on tank house that
you were able to apply to some of those
upcoming titles we're going to talk
about
at that time i it was the first time
that i had been
called to be
a team
leader in that regard in terms of like
the back end i'm a manager i have my
agents and just us
talking and coordinating and us finding
that that
that like timeless groove like the
groove we have now like that groove that
was happening for the first time at that
at that juncture but then i think also
i've started to realize
how
much i had gleaned from daybreak
in terms of just like technical things
the camera
eye lines
um
choices making choices
and how they read on camera because i
feel like a lot of actors get caught up
in like feeling it
but then it's like you could feel it
but we didn't see that we didn't see it
so it's like
knowing what choices read on camera
versus what choices don't and
tank house was whereas daybreak
had a little bit more subtlety in terms
of like the groundedness of the
performance like from a close-ups and
all of that angle like
i could we were let free on tape house i
could just
be crazy and i was like having to be
this introverted character but we can
also be crazy and be that theater kid
that theatrical so
it was it was definitely a learning
experience i think of the range of
techniques that goes into
filmmaking okay so you just handed me my
next question of everyone in the tank
house ensemble whose process is most
similar to yours where you were in sync
the second you hit set but then who did
something like completely different
maybe something that even challenged you
and challenged you for the better
process wise
me and luke
me and luke definitely jailed
um
immediately luke roberts plays brady
my best friend in the and i honestly
initially read for his part
and then i get the get word that i
actually got jack which was a completely
better fit it was but um
it's just so funny how similar
we are to our characters in that respect
because it's like jack is a songwriter
jack is a performer but he's not an
extrovert i'm an extrovert like i'm an
extroverted person i love people i like
know who i am even when i was struggling
with my identity growing up i still knew
who i was it's like you know who austin
is i feel like jack doesn't really know
who he is yet and he's finding his
identity to where it's like him at 25
and jack at 16 and jack at 26
are gonna be two completely different
jacks probably um
and i feel like we just took a very
a very like
grounded just kind of like
social sociological approach to the
character
whereas you know
i feel like steven watching stephen
embody his character
he is so crazy
he's just
so bombastic and every joke he has is
just so funny and he's he's always
improvising something and i think
i learned i i gleaned choices
from him if there was there was one
thing that i learned on that set or got
to experiment with
was choices
like what is what is going to make the
character
pop out what role is the character
playing in this where it's like okay
what what
what as a lead you know with steven
doing that
you know
you know this scene on paper was this
but you know and tara as well tara as
well um like she completely
they both completely elevated
what i read
the characters as before i saw it
i love hearing that
all right so i warned you i want to
touch on two upcoming titles this first
one i'm just like bitter that i missed
it at sun i saw so many wonderful things
at sundance but i missed jesus save your
soul i did see regina's other movie
though so i should be grateful for that
but
i mean regina hall is a damn legend so
please tell me anything about working
from her and anything you took from her
process
just incredible she's everything she's
so down the earth
i was there on set for like only really
a few days and
that she just
has a maternal energy but also a big cis
energy
um that was just very easy to connect
with and sterling as well sterling k
brown
i'm a pastor's kid in real life
um and so i just feel like he played
that pastor so well it was just so well
done but then also he's a big kid
i mean i was doing tick tocks and stuff
on set for those who know me and follow
me i'll be on tick tock i'll be on
twitter and stuff and like
he was just game he was getting into
tick tocks and things like that and he's
just very down-to-earth and sweet and
just one big kid
i love hearing good things about people
that i admire so much
yeah
all right we got another one now a movie
that is no longer called whistler camp
it's called
they slash them and this is this is a
really exciting project because it is
directed by john logan and john logan is
an incredibly accomplished screenwriter
three academy award nominations to his
name but this is his first time behind
the lens of a feature film so was there
anything about his approach to directing
his actors that surprised you or that
you really appreciated
hmm well first of all being included in
any story of this nature is
once in a lifetime once hopefully not
once in a lifetime because we have
this conversation about queerness and
stuff happening now but it was it was
just a one-of-a-kind opportunity because
never have i heard about a horror movie
about a gay conversion camp like that is
just crazy and so
him being at the helm and how he
would have us being our characters and
like asking us
you know what do you think about this
and what do you think about that and
what do you think about you know even
before you know um even before he made a
choice
as a director he would always kind of
bring us into it because we are kind of
this new generation of queer people
that
are dealing with our own things and you
know
he
very
he was very tuned in to the cultural
voice of what was going on as he was
making it and i feel like that is just
incredible because there are some
directors
that maybe they have a vision
but
how it will translate to the outside
world
may be different than what than what the
director has in their head and he
i feel like nailed it
i feel like he nailed this
can't wait i love how i'm like i just
need 15 minutes to talk to you like
we'll get through a lot like no next
time we talk i know i need to request
more time here yes yes i have to let you
go huge congratulations on tank house
and everything you accomplish
we're gonna have many more opportunities
to reconnect about future projects
absolutely absolutely i'll be right
there thank you for having me